afternoon i'm joe gloria registrar
voters in clark county nevada thank you
for being here this afternoon
the purpose of bringing you here today
is to give you some information related
to
when we'll be able to report accurate
numbers
as to what was received on election day
through the mail
and also through our mail ballot
drop-off boxes
we are working feverishly to get all of
that
counted so that we can make an accurate
report
beginning tomorrow in
coinciding with what the secretary of
state will be doing with her reporting
we'll be holding a daily press
conference at 10 a.m
from now until we're done with the
counting process
we're doing this in an effort to provide
transparency
and to give the media an opportunity to
ask any questions related to details
for our mail ballot processing as of
yesterday we've already read all of our
early voting
and all of our election day in-person
voting so
what we have left now is to process
provisional ballots
electronic ballots that were sent to
overseas voters
electronic ballots that were processed
for disabled voters
and also some special ballots for new
residents
again tomorrow at 10 a.m we'll be
prepared to report all of the counts for
what we received through the mail ballot
drop-off what we received in yesterday's
u.s mail and today's u.s mail
every day after that we should have
reports at 10 o'clock giving you updates
on all of those numbers
along with the number of ballots we've
counted
and how many ballots we anticipate we
have left to count
and with that if you have any questions
i'm happy to answer them joe
at this stage how many do you have left
to count
as i mentioned we are not prepared to
give that number
the media is covering up the violent
crime family stealing this election
the media is covering it up the blind
crime family stealing this election
that media is covering up we want our
freedom for the world
give us our freedom to abide in your
body is covering up this election
he's stealing it
where were we what was the last question
was how many ballots are outstanding yet
to count
tomorrow we'll have a number to give you
as far as what we received
in the u.s mail yesterday uh the dropbox
numbers
and today's u.s mail so i i don't have
an accurate number to give you and i
don't want to
give you estimations that's why we're
trying to set this up
for a press conference every day at 10
so i can provide accurate i can tell you
that
we did read mail today that will be
reported tomorrow in alignment with what
the secretary of state is reporting
and we'll have that information tomorrow
on exactly what we have in house
we will also continue to receive mail
due to statutory requirements we have to
continue to receive mail
that was postmarked by november 3rd
through the 10th of november and cures
are
able uh voters who need to cure their
ballot have until november the 12th
which is a week from tomorrow
have you heard from the bible
well we're going to canvas on the 16th
and i have guaranteed to the county
commission that we'll be prepared for
that so
we could be working well into the da
state account which is the 12th
and then we'll be canvassing and
reconciling our records
that we've seen you know yesterday
i'm sorry i'm not clear on exactly what
you're asking are you referring to our
election night reporting
site or the secretaries because i can't
tell you what the secretary of state
does joe the the
date is reporting that almost 62
600 2 000 mail-in ballots have been
returned
statewide and then 413
300 in clark county do you have an
estimate by percentage how many of those
have been counted
as of election night we counted 337 000
mail ballots
so anything over that are in process to
run through
for signature check and through the
counting board
to separate those to be counted i can't
comment on anything
i can't comment on anything as far as
information released from the secretary
of state
you'd need to ask them
if we're running at full bore of full
staff we can process up to 70 000 a day
we're statutorily required to let
anybody witness everything that we can
we've also provided a courtesy to the
observers in the general public and the
democratic and republican party
to monitor our mail-ballot processing
areas
as far as issues we we've had some
issues that we've had to deal with
when those observers sign in they have
to agree to follow the rules that are
guided by statute
if they don't follow those rules we give
them a notice that if they continue to
break the rules
they will be removed from the location
i can't tell you what were the issues oh
they were
consistently trying to interact with our
workers which disrupts their work
uh they may have been rude or um
unprofessional with some of the
colleagues that were there observing
or they wouldn't remain in the
observation area that we clearly defined
in all of the areas
we run on several shifts we have 38
permanent staff members and we have over
300 temporary staff that are working in
two locations
we pull in people from other departments
for election day support
clark county has been very supportive of
voting for many years here so all of our
team leaders on election day are county
employees
and we rely on the county for support in
i.t
the pio several departments that provide
support we can't do it
without help from the entire county
with voting machines in general
yesterday we had some technology issues
that
centered around connectivity to our poll
books there was a small number of issues
with the functionality of signing in our
poll books voting machine issues were
very small
but we were able to react and respond
and get all of our polling places up and
running
joe can you repeat one more time for me
please just the ballots that are still
still outstanding
what you're counting right now you said
provisional yet another few other
categories
what are you counting well what we have
to count in order to complete we have to
counter provisionals we have electronic
ballots that were sent to overseas
voters
also disabled voters have the ability to
use the ease through the secretary of
state's office
and we also have um some some new
resident ballots to go along with those
provisionals
now those are above and beyond mail
ballots that's correct
to stop yes
not as a result of an issue it's a
complicated process when you begin the
process of
bell balance it goes through our agilis
melbourne processing system that's the
first step in the process if it matches
the signature there
those that don't match begin to go
through a manual process
where we send it to an audit team a
bipartisan board and an individual
employee to match that signature
those that still don't match go to the
cure process that's another division
that's doing work
after that they go over to the
accounting board and the accounting
board is responsible that's a bipartisan
board
that's also working to separate the
ballot from the return envelope
they're looking to make sure that
there's no damage on the ballot that
they
voter hasn't identified the ballot
and then that from there it goes to
tabulation so when you say start and
stop
there are several steps in the process
but there have been no issues that have
caused us to stop uh it's just you get
breaks in the action from what's read
and what the next step is
no hey joel quick question how many
ballots per hour can the agilis
machine handle take i know you said that
before
no that's that's all we can read that's
two two different stations there
when we read we can easily process
seventy thousand dollars a day
seven zero seven seventy k seventy
thousand somebody over here
yeah you guys are still counting today
we counted this morning and i believe
that we're finished because we're
entering into the certification process
right now
well we never stopped we've been
counting for many many days and we've
got all the early voting on election day
tomorrow again we'll have processes
going scanning ballots in through the
agilis
so we we can't stop we need to make sure
that we're finishing
how many shapes you're already told but
i couldn't get it how many shapes
you said no counting today they counted
this morning
and they're finished
i can confirm that at tomorrow's 10 a.m
press conference i'll be prepared to
give you all of the numbers that i
previously mentioned
after that every day at 10 a.m including
the weekends
we'll be here to provide you an
opportunity to ask questions
give you an opportunity to hear from me
on the new details and the new counts
and that's the purpose of setting that
up on a daily basis so that you are
aware we'll be here
we want to be sure that we're being
transparent in everything that we're
doing
i can't hear you
how many votes so far oh how many votes
go to the website we've got a report out
there
our results are on the enr uh we we've
counted all of the early voting which
was somewhere in the area of 378.
we had election day turnout last night i
don't have that in my mind
and the mail was uh
check the website i'm sorry i don't have
those numbers in my head joe is there a
sequence that
you use for um counting provisional
electronic overseas disabled new
residents and
did you get any uh help america vote act
balance we had some have a provisionals
yes and there is a process for going
through the provisional that involves us
working with the secretary of state to
verify that we don't have anybody who's
illegally voted
in multiple counties so we work in in
cooperation with the secretary of state
to complete everything we need to do
i have time for one more question
you said from the gop i didn't have any
specific issues from them
other than um issues in the polling
place
regarding some of their observers we
addressed them where we could
but no i haven't had anything provided
to me joe did you say you've got about
337 000
no that's not what i said okay we've
counted 337 i'm
going to have to get back folks that's
the last we'll see you we will be here
again tomorrow at 10 a.m
uh we'll give you some new information
everything that i told you i would
report
as far as the numbers that we received
what we're able
able to get ready to count i will update
that daily at 10 am
thank you very much